ça a été la plus la plus longue
reconstruction que j'ai jamais eu à
faire sur mon intimité sur qui j'étais à
partir du moment où j'ai été formé comme
une plus comme une petite fille mais
comme une jeune femme
j'ai subi des frottements dans le métro
j'ai été suivie à l'âge de neuf ans
jusqu'à mon hall d'entrée et un mec
s'est masturbé devant moi il n'y a pas
quelqu'un dans mon cercle projet qui
n'est pas arrivé et et quand j'avais 16
ans je me suis fait violer par mon
copain de l'époque et des amis à lui et
ça a été ça a été la plus la plus longue
reconstruction que j'ai jamais eu à
faire sur mon intimité sur qui j'étais
mais je connais pas une personne qui a
pas vécu quelque chose qu'il a marqué
autant que ça je connais pas une femme
qui n'a pas vécu ce genre de choses peu
importe l'âge auquel ça arrive ça marque
éternellement et sa force une
reconstruction il faut savoir que toutes
ces violences faites sur les femmes
viennent de personnes dites normales
avec une vie particulièrement difficile
avec une éducation pas particulièrement
compliqué et c'est cette idée là qui est
difficile à intégrer
donc c'est banaliser puisque la plupart
de ces personnes ne se rendent même pas
compte du mal qu'ils font et elle
dédramatise énormément les violences
faites aux femmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le nombre d'amis que l'objet qui sont
réveillés après mitu après valence ton
port en me disant je crois que j'ai déjà
fait quelque chose de mal mais que je
n'étais pas conscient que c'était mal
ben j'imagine que en tant que bourreau
ça doit pas être très agréable cette
remise en question donc il faudrait
juste élevé tout le monde dans le même
sens exactement à prendre aux filles
comme aux garçons ce que c'est que le
consentement ce que c'est que le viol
est ce que c'est que le sexe en général
ce que c'est que tout le harcèlement que
ce soir harcèlement moral ou un
harcèlement physique
si on donne les clés à tout le monde de
la même manière et qu'on leur explique
que ce sont des choses qui sont
illégales et que ce sont pas des choses
pas grave
là on réussira à faire changer les
choses